at first when i saw all the marketing
everywhere for it i assume that arcane
must be pretty bad but riot has
delivered an incredible piece of
standalone storytelling but more than
that it might be the best piece of
narrative media based on a video game
ever on its own that's a massive
accomplishment but it has great
potential to make league of legends a
popular game even more popular and with
a wider audience
and for the first time in the series
history there are options to explore
runeterra that don't involve competition
arcane has absolutely changed the game
and the timing for riot couldn't be
better so let's explore this unique
moment in gaming history and don't worry
i won't spoil anything that the ads
already didn't spoil
[Music]
before we get into it why not take a
moment to sub to the channel click the
notification bell if that's your thing
and if you end up liking the video why
not click the thumber dinger
yeah that sounded a lot better in my
head don't worry you can learn so much
from failure so arcane is an animated tv
series set in runeterra the world of
league of legends it deals primarily
with the regions of piltover and zaun
several champions affiliated with them
and the political and technological
developments that changed the regions
and the lies of these characters the
show was six years in the making and was
spearheaded by french studio fortish who
are already well acquainted with riot
games and helped to produce some of
their most popular cinematics and music
videos that you've probably already seen
and you know how i said i thought the
show would flop in the intro i meant
that i thought that at best we get a
show that league fans could enjoy but
the show has become much more than that
drawing in a massive audience many of
whom can't tell flash and teleport apart
i really want to emphasize how different
this is from the norm this isn't a wow
addict dragging their friend to the
warcraft movie or your dad going to see
the angelina jolie tomb raider flex this
is a series receiving critical acclaim
while attracting league of legends fans
and just regular casual netflix viewers
league of legends is the most played
game on the planet and already boasts a
massive fan base for example the grand
finals at league worlds 2021 boasted
73.8
million concurrent viewers that's like
if nearly the entire population of
canada got cloned and then all sat down
to watch the same thing and thankfully
that only happened one time i think my
clone lives in sweden now which is
pretty cool for him anyways what i'm
trying to say is that the nine episode
first season of arcane broke out of the
video game niche and into the mainstream
and even here at the score the level of
excitement around this series differed
wildly
so what did it feel like to have people
praising something associated with
league of legends really weird to be
honest because
like i was like my whole thing
for years has been like playing league
you just
it always feels like you're at the
center of like
controversy right because it's just
always
it's always been called like a toxic
game and you know there's always like
riot gets memed on a lot
and league does too
and just for this one week or two it's
been like
hey maybe it's okay to play league maybe
like
you know
i'm not saying it's cool but you know i
think it's
it's kind of nice to just scroll through
twitter and
see people being positive about the game
even from within the community right for
just a week or two there isn't a lot of
negativity around league of legends
and it's kind of cool yeah yeah
for myself i obviously watch league of
legends and write about it and i play
legends of runeterra casually when i
feel like it but i don't exactly own a
lot of runeterra merch my interest in
the game skews heavily towards the
esports side of things so when i saw
riot's mick montgomery tweet this
i was honestly extremely skeptical it
seemed like obvious hyperbole about a
show that would have a clearly niche
audience but you don't need to know
anything about the world to enjoy the
show and that's what's making arcane so
successful
it's a show about loyalty about progress
about the immorality and peril of
ignoring society's most vulnerable
people yeah it focuses on a bunch of
champions from the game but they're just
characters they're not held up as icons
to be reverently worshiped instead the
series spins a narrative with these
characters old and new alike like i said
earlier arcane has just exploded it's
currently the highest rated netflix
original show on imdb while over at
rotten tomatoes it boasts a 98 audience
score and a 100 critic score it's also
one of the most watched shows on netflix
with act one's release going to number
one on netflix in 38 different countries
and the show's success could not have
come at a better time for the first time
in the eyepiece history there are
multiple options to delve into the world
of runeterra that have nothing to do
with competition at all but how did we
get to that point let's rewind to 2019
when riot announced a bevy of games and
other projects as part of their 10th
anniversary celebration you're going to
see us try a lot of different ways for
you to engage with the world of league
of legends from comics to novels
board games
music videos tv i know this all sounds a
little crazy but like with everything we
do we're going to look to you to let us
know what's working and we'll double
down on those areas i'm not gonna lie
this did sound crazy at the time just
like ghost crawler said
sure some people are gonna buy a comic
about lux or whatever it worked for wow
after all but when they showed a stinger
for a league of legends tv show it just
seemed like a stretch especially given
the production budgets that would be
involved in creating something like that
but like i said just a moment ago riot
games not only said that they were going
to aim for tv but also that they were
going to release a ton of new games
something that was new to the company
legends of runeterra a card game project
l a league of legends fighting game and
project a the game that would later be
released as valorent they also showed
off a standalone mobile app for team
fight tactics and announced the creation
of a mobile only version of league of
legends called wild rift with the
exception of project l all of these
games have been released and generally
they've been well received but back in
2019 that seemed far from certain team
fight tactics was basically league of
legends units with a
borrowed formula and it was still part
of the league of legends client beyond
that riot just had league they were
constantly being memed on for being
called riot games even though they
pretty much only had one game and yes
that game was extremely successful it
was one of the world's most popular
esports but i think as we've seen in the
past that isn't a guarantee of future
success now as arcane has taken off and
tied in with all of the games that i
just mentioned fans have more ways than
ever to interact with the world of
runeterra in fact the riot forge
initiative which was announced a couple
months after that anniversary stream
that we talked about saw riot partner
with developers to create games set in
runeterra but which weren't competitive
at all ruined king and hextech mayhem
two games produced as a result of riot
forge are two very different experiences
one is a turn-based rpg the other is a
music game but they are both
approachable and more importantly they
are available right as arcane has
increased interest in league of legends
in an absolutely unprecedented way is
your dad going to hit challenger is your
aunt going to be bothering you to cue
valorant every night
probably not but the success of arcane
is potentially a huge boon to league of
legends and riot games league of legends
didn't need to be saved really as i said
the game is massively popular and its
esport viewership is among the biggest
in the world but that popularity was
within a specific demographic pc gamers
within a certain age range basically
arcane changes that when it returned for
act two it hit number one on netflix in
52 countries at the very least this
popularity translates to mainstream
cultural cachet realistically it puts a
face or several to a name that people
outside the demographic i mentioned had
probably at least heard of but it
probably also brings some of them in
even if they're loading into a
standalone switch rpg instead of
summoner's rift and these first few riot
forge titles show that there's deep
potential for more games set in this
world plus let's not forget that one of
their competitors is facing some pretty
tough times of their own
and there's blood in the water in fact
back when overwatch's cinematic trailer
released the pixar level animation sure
made it seem like blizzard would be the
ones to create a critically acclaimed
animated series before anyone else and
while their animation team has
absolutely killed it in recent years
there's nothing like arcane on the
horizon and even if there was a secret
project on that scale releasing it
wouldn't cause employees and fans who
are frustrated about the current
situation with blizzard to just forget
that those things exist riot's own
record on that front you'll recall is
far from spotless and that absolutely
should not be lost in this discussion
finally a note about tv and movies based
on video games they just haven't been
that good
ever and listen i'm not here to argue
with you about which ones are good i
think it's fair to say that most of them
are somewhere between below average to
atrocious and that even the ones that we
might consider good are received by
critics and by many audiences as mostly
mediocre at best i really think arcane
has changed all that though
now we have the potential to see more
successful adaptations or at least
attempts at them because this was
clearly popular the high quality of
animation and storytelling brought in
people who otherwise weren't invested in
league of legends and that is what will
bring people to do this again the
popularity and success of arcane will
inspire other companies to take their
own shot so what do you guys think how
big an impact do you think arcane will
have
and though i hesitate to ask this are
there any pieces of video game media
that you earnestly believe are better
than arcane let me know in the comments
below i'm gonna go play some legends of
runeterra
really digging deep into that nine
o'clock energy here we go
just i should just i should just hit
some g fuel before i do this in the
future i'm sure that will give me some
great results
i did i actually did drink g-fuel
unironically a couple times danny
i don't know